SPIN ON THE CLASS OF 2019 MAY
HAVE GOTTEN AN UNEXPECTED
TORTURE SYSTEM FROM
HILLARY CLINTON, USING HER
COMMENCEMENT SPEECH AT HUNTER
COLLEGE TO GET POLITICAL.
ATTACKING PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
RUSSIA PROBE, AND MORE, WATCH.
>> OUR DEMOCRACY FEELS FAR FROM
SECURE.
THEY BANNED MUSLIMS FROM
ENTERING THE COUNTRY.
AND OUR GOVERNMENT IS TEARING
CHILDREN FROM THE ARMS OF THEIR
PARENTS AT THE BORDER.
AND LOCKING THEM IN CAGES.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
WE ARE WITNESSING AN ASSAULT ON
THE RULE OF LAW AND THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
WHAT DO WE DO WHEN PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY ARE NOT
HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
WHEN THEY DEFY REQUEST FROM THE
CONGRESS?
WHEN FACEBOOK REFUSED TO TAKE
DOWN A FAKE VIDEO OF
NANCY PELOSI.
IT WAS NOT EVEN A CLOSE CALL,
THE VIDEO IS SEXIST TRASH.
>> Katie: SO GREG, HILARY WAS
SO BRAVE THAT SHE WANTED TO GO
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
30 MINUTES AND DID NOT SAY HIS
NAME.
>> Greg: YOU ARE REMINDED HOW
DIFFERENT AND IRRELEVANT THE
TYPICAL POLITICAL ORATORY HAS
BECOME.
WHEN YOU ARE LISTENING TO HER,
YOU JUST GO, THE MEDIA IS LYING
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE PREFERRED
THAT OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
BECAUSE HE HAS MADE POLITICS
INTERESTING FOR ONCE, SHE IS
JUST OLD AND TIRED, AND I MEAN
THAT, LISTEN TO ARE NOT AS A
PERSON.
HE HAS ACTUALLY BROUGHT PEACE
AND PROSPERITY, WHILE VOLATILITY
IN HIS PERSONALITY.
TO GET THE SUCCESS AND
ACHIEVEMENT SO THAT YOU CAN
STILL ENJOY HIS PERSONALITY AND
NOT FEEL BAD.
BY THE WAY, SHE IS SPEAKING --
SHE WAS ASKED TO SPEAK AT A
CYBERSECURITY SYMPOSIUM.
THAT IS LIKE ASKING MICHAEL
MOORE TO SPEAK AT WEIGHT
WATCHERS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE AT ALL AND I
CANNOT WAIT TO HEAR THAT SPEECH.
>> Katie: SHE IS KEYNOTING THE
CYBER DEFENSE SUMMIT WITH THE
WORLD'S LEADING CYBER EXPERTS.
MAYBE THEY CAN TEACH HER
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: THEY ARE PAYING HER.
>> Katie: LIKE A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS.
BUT DANA, YOU HAVE GIVEN ADVICE
TO GRADUATES, ISN'T IT REALLY
UNFAIR THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD TAKE AWAY THIS MOMENT FROM
THEM TO TALK ABOUT YOURSELF?
>> Dana: IF I WAS IN THE
AUDIENCE I WOULD BE LIKE I DON'T
FEEL VERY INSPIRED RIGHT NOW.
HOWEVER, A LITTLE BIT OF
RESEARCH, THE GRADUATES THAT
WERE THERE LIKED IT.
SO I THINK THAT --
>> Greg: THEY ARE BRAINWASHED.
>> Juan: THEY ARE INTERESTED
IN --
>> Greg: THEIR PROFESSORS TELL
THEM WHAT TO THINK.
THAT'S HOW THEY GET THEIR
GRADES.
COME ON, WE KNOW.
WE KNOW.
>> Juan: YOU ARE JUST UNHAPPY.
>> Greg: I'M HAVING A GREAT
TIME.
I AM HAVING A GREAT TIME.
SPEED BY IF YOU WOULD PREFER IF
BOTH IN THE WHITE HOUSE --
>> Greg: YOU ARE RUNNING?
>> Juan: WE HAVE THE REAL ONE.
BUT I MEAN SERIOUSLY, THE
GRADUATES PREFER SOMEONE WHO
WOULD HAVE TAKEN AWAY ALL OF
THEIR --
'S BEFORE THE WINTER?
ROBERT SMITH?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY QUESTION THAT THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN CURRENT AFFAIRS,
THEY ARE SMART PEOPLE, THEY ARE
GRADUATING WITH A DEGREE AND
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON.
YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE WHO
KNOWS WHAT IS GOING ON,
HILLARY CLINTON AND TO TALK
ABOUT CYBERSECURITY, SHE MAY BE
THE GREATEST VICTIM OF CYBER
SECURITY.
>> Katie: OH, COME ON, JUAN.
HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD GIVE A
SPEECH AT THE CYBERSECURITY
SUMMIT ABOUT HOW TO START AN
ILLEGAL SERVER FROM YOUR
BASEMENT OR YOUR BATHROOM.
SHE COULD TEACH PEOPLE.
>> Juan: OR HOW WE ARE
PROTECTING AMERICA AGAINST MORE
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
SPEAK TO YOU DO NOT HAVE SOME
GUY HAND OVER THE PASSWORD TO
THE HACKER.
LIKE JOHN PODESTA DID TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS SPEECH WAS SO BAD I DON'T
EVEN THINK THE GRADUATES THROUGH
THEIR HATS UP IN THE AIR.
THEY WERE ALL FALLING ASLEEP.
I WOULD HAVE TO DISAGREE, ON
"WATTERS' WORLD," WE HAD A
FAMILY THAT WAS SO DISGUSTED
THAT SHE WENT OFF THE RAIL, AND
HE WAS UPSET BECAUSE HE PAID ALL
OF THE MONEY TO HAVE THE
DAUGHTER GO TO HUNTER COLLEGE,
AND SHE THOROUGHLY HUMILIATES
HERSELF, SHE CANNOT READ A ROOM
EITHER.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE INSPIRING
AND UPLIFTING, AND NOBODY WANTS
TO HEAR --
>> Greg: IT WAS ABOUT HER.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO KNOW HOW
MUCH SHE GOT PAID, BECAUSE,
HUNTER COLLEGE, I WOULD DO IT
FOR HALF OF THAT.
>> Greg: I LIKE THAT YOU HAVE
THE PHONE SIGN, BECAUSE THEY
STILL USE THE PHONE.
>> Katie: ISN'T THAT THE POINT
THAT YOU PAY TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND YOU PAY THESE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF SPEAKER FEES, AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET INTO THE
REAL WORLD, AND IT IS HIJACKED
BY SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT HERSELF AND ISSUES THAT
ARE UNRELATED TO SCHOOL.
>> Greg: IT IS NOT HIJACKING,
IT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
>> Katie: A PARENT WHO HAS
PAID HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS, AND YOU HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THAT.
>> Greg: THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR DECADES, THEY HAVE
LIBERAL COMMENCEMENT SPEAKERS.
THEY HAVE A LIBERAL
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS ONE BIG LIBERAL LOVE FEST.
WHEN I SEE THIS, IT IS LIKE
BEING SURPRISED WHEN YOU FIND
GARBAGE AT THE DUMP.
>> Dana: A LOT OF COMMENCEMENT
SPEAKERS, NOT AS MUCH OF THIS
YEAR, BUT IN 2016 COMING SAW A
LOT OF COMMENCEMENT SPEAKERS USE
IT AS A CHANCE TO MAKE NEWS.
IT WAS LIKE OH, OKAY.
WHAT CAN YOU DO TO GET ON CABLE
NEWS?
>> Jesse: IT IS WHY SHE IS
STAYING IN THE GAME, SHE THOUGHT
THE INSURANCE POLICY WOULD KICK
IN, HE WOULD GET IMPEACHED, AND
SHE WOULD RUN IN 2020 AS THE
RIGHTFUL HEIR TO THE THRONE,
BECAUSE SHE WAS ROBBED AND SHE
WOULD RESTORE THE CLINTON
DYNASTY.
>> Greg: SHE KEPT HER SERVER
ON A THRONE.
>> Juan: I'M SURPRISED THAT
YOU ARE NOT SAYING LOCK HER UP,
BECAUSE YOU ARE STILL HATING ON
HILLARY.
THOSE GRADUATES AND THEIR
PARENTS ARE GOING TO ALWAYS
REMEMBER WHO SPOKE AT THAT
GRADUATION AND THEY ARE